hello youtube chess lovers and my
friends this is gunjan here
have you ever imagined that once in a
lifetime you play a game
where you
attack to your opponent from the
starting point
and even though let's say your one two
or maybe three to four pcs are hanging
and still instead of capturing those
species
your opponent tried to save his king so
his king will run like a hell
and after all the deep calculations and
big tactical blows
you caught his king
i think that kind of feeling will give
you a satisfaction which no other chess
game can give you
and that is exactly our part of
discussion today
because i'm going to show you a game
which is one of my own favorite game
of attacking chess
and
i must tell you that
this game put great impact on me in fact
from this game i learned exactly what
you mean by real chess
to give you a brief history uh this game
was played
way back in 1974 between rafael vaganyan
and
viktor kopreczek soviet union
championship in the game vaganian was
wide and vaganian start with the move d4
and cooperate reply with the knight to
f6 so it's a standard moves and here
comes
one of my own favorite opening which is
bishop to g5 so you can see uh it's
attacking the knight and try to [ __ ]
the black pawns
and copra chick here
choose one of the aggressive reply of
the black and he played c5 so it's
counter attacking the white center
and of course vaganian played d5 so
grabbing the space
and
here comes a very logical move by
coprachi which is queen to b6
now you can see
because
white has moved his bishop in early
stages it's very very logical for black
to attack on the b2 square which is the
weakest spot right now in the camp white
camp but here comes a big surprise to
the corporation because here the first
time
a gambit occurs which in fact the name
has been given
vagani and gambit and
vaganian played this amazing move which
is knight to c3
so completely gambiting the pawn
and
at first sight it doesn't look like
white has any compensation and
copra chick of course when he was facing
this gambit first time
he decided to test the white idea by
capturing the phone
and now you can see the white knight is
hanging so the only logical reply here
for the white is
bishop to d2 and from here onwards now
you will see
every single move the white
will attack the black
and we will see a great fireworks so the
first thing you can notice is black
cannot play a very random move for
example if black can play g6 white can
immediately play this rook to b1 so
attacking the queen queen has only one
place to go so after queen to a3
knight to b5 you can see this knight is
not only attacking the queen but it's
also eyeing the c c7 square and the
thing is the queen cannot go to the
critical square e5 because the blade
bishop has been eyeing on that square so
white at least will be exchange off so
that's why it's very important at this
point that black has to
retrieve his queen and koplachik play
queen to b6
and here comes the whole idea of
gambiting the pawn so white has gambit
upon to make a very very fast
development in the center and take out
the pieces very very fast
so here comes e4 so now you can see
uh if it has been allowed then
vaganian will play e5 and embarrass the
knight
so completely stop that by playing d6
but now comes the another amazing move
which is f4 so now wagon enforce the
issue with the f4 so now e5 is
definitely on the card i have shown you
here by the arrow that if the knight to
d7 will happen then white can play
knight to f3 and again e5 will be there
so there is there is no way black can
stop this so after long thinking
uh coproce decided to play g6
so he decided to counter this attack
with the rapid fast development of his
own pcs
but nevertheless e5 comes so it's
attacking the knight so first black
capture that pawn and after white
recapture black plays knight to d7
attacking the e5
and white carrying out the peace
development so right now you can see
white has a tremendous peace development
and not only that white has amazing
center so these two pawns are exerting
great pressures on the black camp
here corporation decided to play bishop
to g7 so now he's attacking the e5
square and here the bombarding starts
the white start with the move rook to b1
so now it's attacking the queen now you
can see queen cannot go to the a5 square
then otherwise it has to face the
discovery
or if the queen goes to c7 then he has
to face this bow which is d6 so now you
can see it's attacking the pawn attack
attacking the queen and if black take
the pawn then he has to face the smoke
knight is not only attacking the queen
but it's also attacking the critical dc
square which comes with the check and
black king will be misplaced
so of course at this point queen has
only one square which is queen has to go
back to d8 and that was exactly played
in the game
and here the fireworks start with the
move
e6
so you can see right now the pawn is
attacking the tonight and the f7 square
so black decided to first capture this
one of the pawn
but
here he has to face a amazing move here
which is
knight to g5
and now you can see
this knight if his it has been allowed
then it will go to the e6 and it will
fork the queen and the bishop
so black somehow has to respond to this
and
in the game black played knight to f6 so
it's very logical the bishop is now
protecting the pawn so knight if the
knight cross e6 happen then black will
capture the knight here vaganian play
first of all the swami's above which is
bishop check you can see if any minor
pieces for example bishop or the knight
comes in between the check
then
again knight e6 will be happen and that
will for queen and the bishop so that's
why
poor copper chick has to play this move
which is
king to f8
but now we're gonna capture the pawn
and now you can see it's indeed
threatening knight to f7
so
of course
there is no way
black can stop this so black decided to
counter this with the move a6
now it's very logical because
let's say if the knight have seven
happen then the idea of the black is to
capture that bishop and then capture the
knight in the corner so at least it will
have a rook for the two pieces
but however this is not the ghanian
meghanian at this point played a amazing
move
i'll give you a few seconds can you find
a amazing move over here
and the amazing move is bishop to e3
now
first thing is white queen is attacking
the black queen and not only that white
has ignored the threat of pawn takes
bishop
now
when we start of a chess there is a
general rule of chess is when you are
attacking you do not want to exchange
your queen so you want your queen to be
participate in the attack
but here this is one of the good
exception because
vaganian clearly see that
if the queen has been exchanged then the
resulting position is very much
favorable to the white
so let's see what happened if here
black
take the queen so for example queen
cross v1 then white will simply
recapture the queen and now you can see
black does not have any time to capture
this bishop because
the rook check comes into the picture so
for example if black greedily capture
the bishop over here then white can play
rook chat and after knight comes in
between
white can simply castle over here again
giving a check
and after bishop to f6
fight can play this move which is take
c8 and see the position of the white not
only white is exchanged up
but see the [ __ ] position of the
black pieces they all are sitting it
backwards that's why
exchanging in the queen will will be a
bad idea for the black
and that's why very wisely cooperative
decide to play this move which is queen
to a5 now you can see right now there
are two pcs are hanging of the white so
bishop is hanging
and knight is hanging and a normal
player or let's say even 2000 plus
player
will think okay i have to defend one of
my piece but gm vaganyan is a very
amazing attacking player and he come out
with a very amazing move which is
casp
and i can demonstrate over here black
cannot even touch those pieces
so for example if queen cross c3
then we have queen to d8 check mate
so that's the first thing first piece
cannot be captured
and second is if the a captures b5 then
after rook captures
the queen has to stay in this diagonal
to stop the mate so the only logical
square left is queen to c7
but afterwards we have knight to d5 so
again attacking the queen please note
this piece is right now pin so knight
cannot capture this knight so the queen
has to go
either to
d8 or e5 if queen goes to d8
then
we have a very good simple line which
can runs like this so first while play
this amazing move which is rook takes f6
and after
bishop takes f6
we have
knight to f7 so attacking queen and a
rook so it's very logical queen has to
play queen to d8 so it's counter
attacking the rook but after knight to
d6 not only protecting the rook but also
attacking the queen
so the black has to forcefully capture
the knight and after bishop to at six
track bishop to g7 queen to f3 check
king to g8 and knight to f6 shack
it's [ __ ] the king and the queen so
black has to capture this knight and
after queen takes f6
you can see the mate is threatened on g7
and the amazing part is black cannot
defend you can see all the squares queen
has
not allowed to gain access on the
squares see the wonderful position of
the white that will happen if queen to
d8 has been played the most logical
square looks like queen to e5 but here
again
white can play this move which is bishop
to c5
and it's a time for the group photo
see it's a dream position of any
attacking player you can see one two
three four pieces are on the fifth rank
of the
opponent and all the pcs of the opponent
are sitting behind or they are slipping
a sample line can be wrong like this so
if the black queen captured one of the
pieces of the wire
then white can play this move which is
bishop jack and after king goes to g8
white can play this move knight to f6
and no matter how
it captured whether it's captured by the
queen or the bishop the meat has been
threatened
and black king will not survive longer
so after considering all this
at this point
coprachick decide to play
this move which is at six
and
it's time to pause for a moment you can
see right now
black is attacking three pieces of the
white so right now
this knight is hanging
and this knight is hanging and this
bishop is hanging
but
see the attacking ability of ghanian and
vaganyan completely ignore these three
pieces
and goes for this wonderful move which
is queen to d3 and now you can see the
idea is very very simple so white wants
to play queen cross g6 and then
made the black key on f7
and the question is how the black going
to defend this
so for example
if here
black greedily capture this s h cross g5
then white can play this move queen
cross g6 and at first side it looks like
black has defended the position after
bishop cross e6
but this checkmate
so you can see this knight cannot
capture the queen so that's why h cross
g6 is not possible
so though that leads to the only
possibility left which is which has been
played in the game by the coprachick
which is king to g8
but
nevertheless white continues with the
queen cross g6
and again you can see black cannot
capture the knight if black foolishly
captured the knight
then we have
checkmate in three
so it's a very simple one first of all
queen check and after king goes to the
h7 we have a bishop jack
and okay white black can play some
pieces in between but that's not a
logical way the only square left for the
black king is to h6 and then white can
checkmate
so that's why still
even at this position
after queen cross g6 black
cannot touch either of the three pieces
so the only thing left for the black
is to play this move which is bishop
cross e6
it's okay black has given up a piece but
you can see right now white's two pieces
are also hanging so probably uh
coprachick thought that if i can get rid
of that pawn then i can save my mate and
then i can look for for some kind of
counter
but
we're gonna diffuse everything with a
style so he first of all play this move
so knight takes
e6 so now you can see the mate he's made
has been threatened so the only move
left is
rook to h7
but after this
i give you a few seconds can you spot a
amazing move over here
and the move is
rook takes f6 bam
and
you can see
right now again the three pieces are
hanging but black cannot capture either
of the three pieces because queen to e8
and mid has been threatened
and
in the game copper chick played the last
move which is knight to d7 but after
bishop takes d7
see the beauty about this game
throughout this game black was
threatening to capture
at least two to three pieces but the end
when he resigned
whites all pcs are on the board
including the queen and black doesn't
get even time for capturing of one piece
so this was one of the very amazing game
by the wagonian which teaches how
actually you can have a real attack on
the opponent i still hope that one day
i'll play a game like this and i think
that will be dream of many of us i hope
you enjoy and learn a very good
attacking game please feel free to
comment on my video and i'll meet you
soon bye